hey here we go ready watch here we go
[Laughter]
[Music]
ah the moats man it's been too long
being in his home is always my chance to
learn more about the one thing i love
hamburgers so today i'm really excited
to reunite and have him show me not just
one but three influential burgers from
his hometown
burgers that are a window into his past
let the regional tour begin
we're back
we're at the burger show with
my man the burger scholar himself
george moats in the house that burgers
built
yeah i can call that yeah the journey
started here we're eight seasons in oh
wow i'm so excited to be here because
every time i come over i learn something
new i'm here to make sure everybody gets
it right it gets keeps it straight and
gets the history right right and also
understand this method's out there it's
not just one type of hamburger right
this is what's key because
people just think hamburger is just a
hamburger
but we think hamburgers are everything
else but just a hamburger it's like life
it's an expression of the american
ingenuity culture it's the american
story so where are we going today well
today so i decided to dial everything
back way back right to my hometown this
is like x-men origins but this
burger show burger scholar origins i
grew up in new york i grew up in long
island during the pandemic i couldn't
get out there and i started thinking
about my hometown burgers i've never
really thought about my hometown burgers
ever you know i mean these are the
burgers that basically made me who i am
so they're just very simple burgers
they're easy to make this season we'll
be doing a lot of crazy wild
over-the-top sauce i saw so this is
super comforting for me good and you
know when you come here you're gonna get
authenticity yeah and you're gonna get
simplicity all these burgers we're gonna
make today have been around for at least
or more than 50 years
so
that's a dream longer than i've been
around we're gonna make three burgers
today the shambi from west hampton beach
we're gonna make the chester from quag
and we're gonna make the crispy fried
onion burger from triangle pub in
eastport okay let's go yoo-hoo let's do
this i'm ready let's go who's hungry
okay the first burger okay from my
hometown diner dave's bunnenberger i see
ham so there's nothing on it it's
nothing but a cheeseburger okay with
some cooked ham on top and it's called
the shambi the cheese hamburger oh
now it sounds simple yeah that's kind of
stupid it goes back to the 1970s toasted
bun over here first let that sit there
right now i use okay the hand smash
method for this okay they do hand form
patties but i'd prefer to like do this
and that's it see
this
wow there you go right
that's it slime is key gorgeous small
burger but big burger energy
this is nothing more
than just shaved ham okay i'm gonna go
and flip this one you're good here i
think
there you go
normally what he would do now
is they would take and put it in the
broiler okay and they um and a
salamander okay to melt the cheese i'm
not doing that so i'm gonna do this
instead cover it up
bam
oh my god look at
is that over there it's so melty
oh my god oh god oh my god
i got i mean it's like
you can eat this burger and you're gonna
save yourself
why didn't i think of that
that is perfection
oh dude i mean
look at that burger that's the champion
i've never seen anything like it george
let me give this a try burger number one
burger number one the shabby the shabby
i got that really good nugget of ham
right there i don't know if you guys
should see that
oh
move over bacon yeah i don't need bacon
i don't i'm not a big bacon burger guy
name am i
ham is where it's at yeah no pretense
zero pretense or ingredients walking
into this a ham sandwich is a ham
sandwich a burger is a burger keep it
separate right this makes sense now
after eating it okay ready on the next
burger
number two
the chester you've heard of this one yes
i've seen it i've loved it i want to
taste it so this actually is a chester
this was invented over 50 years ago by a
guy named chester my name is chester and
so is this hamburger they were out doing
some you know drinking okay and uh got
home and i had no burger buns so they
took a burger patty and put it inside
two pieces of bread basically made a
grilled cheese with a burger patty
inside but what happened next is
important because chester took her to
his beach club okay in my hometown and
told the concession could you make this
burger we made last night so they made
it okay then he went away he moved to
spain for four years he came back and
they were calling it the chester oh on
the menu as the chester he became a
legend
that's a mold this is an official
chester mold from the restaurant that
makes them in my hometown square patty
yeah see it's perfect look at that see
how it lines up perfectly it looks like
a little bit but that's it shrink it'll
be perfect this is a a three ounce ball
of beef so what i'm going to do
is just press this in and form this
right why is bread square you know why i
don't there you go
yeah why is it it's because of
efficiency
back in the early days of train travel
right a guy named pullman okay came with
the idea why don't we
make the bread spread loaf square so
they'll fit into the drawers in the
kitchen on the train
so you got to start by thinking of a
grilled cheese right okay we think of a
grilled cheese what is it it's spacing
there butter right but here i'm going to
start with two slices of cheese oh
look perfect square look at that people
look at this you see this squared patty
salt
beef cheese bread that's the whole thing
that's it this is a quintessential
classic long island dish this is really
contained in my hometown this is a
secret handshake you got to know
somebody
ah
there's no like online documented
situation and that's it that's the whole
oh this is going to be a reddit thread
here we go that's it see that it's a
grilled cheese no wait it's a hamburger
no it's both the structure
no flop no that thing is crisp no score
right okay
look at that
actually perfectly fine perfectly cooked
just perfect now what you're going to
notice right away
unlike most cheeseburgers this has two
slices of cheese this has twice the
amount of cheese cheese and it also has
a buttered toasted surface on both sides
both sides oh my gosh
not good
oh
damn
that's just that just shot up there as
one of my favorites
truly one of the formative burgers of my
life this is it for me the chester this
is a life-changing burger
wow it is oh
i mean in like the
the the realm of meat cheese bun you
know having louise lunch yeah having an
original patty mill
now eating the chester
i've come full circle this is best this
kind of reminds you of louis lunch
burger right
this is top
on the next
hometown burger number three the crispy
onion burger from triangle pub in
eastport we got extra equipment oh we
got a lot of equipment here but again a
very simple burger been around since the
1930s oh long time this is actually a
very straightforward bar burger but it's
so big that they have to serve it on a
kaiser roll okay the idea of having a
burger at a bar
actually started because bar owners
wanted to keep people in the bars locked
they're drinking yeah all right so
originally if you ever go to a bar and
there's a griddle right behind the bar
at some point way back in time those
burgers were free
whoa that's right i'm kind of known for
onions on a burger yes you are
and so this is something different a
little bit different it's a regular
cheeseburger but on top of the burger
instead of being pressed in on top of
the burger or crispy fried onions oh
that's you know it's not not the cheap
[ __ ] you find like you know you can you
dump it on the can you know this is the
real deal yeah not the green bean
casserole no no no 12 ounces
12 ounces 12 ounces of beef look at that
it's nearly a pound
we're gonna get this thing to a pretty
wide because you know the kaiser roll's
pretty taking a while yeah it's gonna
take a while so let's get a little
thinner but wider yeah so here we go
here we go salt on there there's a
little needle a lot of stuff this is
next the kaiser roll buttered bun oh
[ __ ] butter your bun everything's hot
that's hot this is uh this is a george
most booby trap right here
look at that
okay
toasting a bun so we're going to do it
these are these are actually they're
rings i mean they're look at the rings
see that look at that perfect ring so
what we're going to do
is we're just going to slice it okay
twice this way and twice that way okay
so we end up with this they're not
perfectly around she's going to go over
i'm going to add some seasoned salt yeah
to flour
you always have to season your flour you
gotta season your flour yep there you go
put that in there
[Music]
now with this very special device thank
you very much okay this is a little cool
doodad that i made okay this is a sifter
they use these for deep frying
everything it's a big surprise it's like
a miner's uh small spreaders thing it's
really looking for gold yeah there you
go look at that look how chefy you are
okay this is going directly into here
okay you've seen this before and
all right there
give it a little shake
it's like the perfect size and here we
go into the oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
sorry
that was i didn't mean to have that
happen that was dangerous shut it off
sorry it's okay nothing happened here
look at that look at this
this over here
like i'm actually going to put two
slices of cheese
right might as well
here we go okay we can get this oh [ __ ]
okay look at that the cut it kind of
bubbled up a little bit
oh god mondo bird that's a big one okay
now okay
while the cheese is still hot
we're gonna put
crispy fried eggs on top of it but now
when i go to triangle pub i always get a
double order
oh yeah so just so you know
oh [ __ ] there it is
oh look at that thing look at that thing
it's big and it's a big burger you know
what's funny is that this looks like
something you would get at a good bar
yeah exactly you know that's something
you want right
oh yeah
oh
perfectly cooked okay
let me say that
oh yeah dude oh my god
the onions are key yeah the onions are
clutch because there's a little bit a
little bit of crunch in there you know
and you know what the kaiser roll has
enough structure
for this to make sense
that is fantastic you're a lucky man
growing up and eating this burger yeah
that's special thank you so of the three
burgers we've made from my hometown this
question is gonna happen
this is gonna happen of the three
burgers you had from my hometown if you
could pick a favorite which i can't by
the way could you pick a favorite i can
okay i can i could clearly pick one the
chester burger yeah fantastic oh good
okay i think you made it so perfectly
that's why there was it was flawless
thank you you get crunch cheese meat
cheese crunch there's a lot going on
with with little ingredients yeah
sometimes you have to dial back to the
simple stuff yeah just to remember where
you came from i know for sure i'll be
making the chester a lot good that was
fun man that was fun always a pleasure
always a pleasure coming to the burger
mecca thanks for being here thank you so
much man
burger show season eight we're out
peace
[Music]
what's up y'all it's your boy alvin
kylon of the burger show make sure you
like
subscribe and hit that notification bell
if not for me
for the burger